my name is villo i'm
data person working at Porsche digital
labna yeah and today before I jump in I
would ask you a quick question does
anyone know what this means okay it's
not a bad word yeah it's that's that's
in sign language saying my name is villo
so 5 to 10% of the world's population is
hard-of-hearing or a lot our deaf and
relies on sign language as their primary
form of communication and then and in
this project I wanted to start to build
a system which can which can deal with
that so more specifically oops get a
bullet point okay sorry okay cool so
specifically I focus on the American
sign language because it's in English
and I can speak English and also they
have a very active online forum which is
important for me to get data so every
country has its own sort of sign
language is a German sign language
British sign language I focus on the
American sign language and specifically
on the alphabet so I had to I started
out trying to translate the entire sign
language and it was a bit much given the
time constraints so the American sign
language is 26 letters much like ours
it's used to spell your name and also in
sign language there's roughly ten to
thirty thousand words in the dictionary
compared to English where there's almost
200 thousand and so when there's when
there's a word which you can't say you
literally spell it out so that was sort
of the use case of that yep and today I
want to though just walk you through
this initial pipeline I made so this was
a project for me as well to to get
better and to learn more about deep
learning and building systems and like
most machine learning systems we start
with the data some pre-processing
feature extraction in machine learning
to focus on using convolutional neural
networks and specifically
for learning with the limited amount of
data and put it in a into a real-time
system the tech stack beautifulsoup was
great being a video camera just to keep
it old-school for image pre-processing I
use open CV Python pillow and then sites
I can learn care as an AWS so I'll throw
in a little bit of code here for carers
and open ZB just to show how sort of
easy they make machine learning and
transfer learning these days everyone's
people use it open CV and carers before
oh yeah okay cool
so first what does sign language look
like that's that's an a for example to
start off with the data I just wanted to
quickly iterate so I managed there's one
open source data set available it for a
sign language this is the american sign
language boston university corpus around
1,500 images of equally balanced classes
it's very clean you can use cropped take
on a green screen so i took this as a
starting point and went ahead to to just
test out with it I'm just quickly yeah
this is an example of sign language so
that's a UV and a W fairly distinct but
then as you see like an A and Evan and
then it becomes extremely similar so
it's a little it's a bit of a challenge
the first step when I take the data was
just a little bit of pre-processing to
get it to work with the transfer
learning model and I'll talk about the
model in some detail later so we take
the image we just make it into a square
and Pat it resize it for the neural
network architecture and at the end of
it had roughly 1,500 images 55-foot
class which is not a lot and so I also
deal with some data augmentation later
this is also why I use transfer running
so I took this and I ran it through the
vgg 16 architecture just for 50 bucks
and I got these like very pretty curves
and I thought well I've cracked it like
this is Gary this is going to work and I
let's move on to the real-time system
to see how it actually works and OpenCV
makes it very simple using the video
capture object so this connects to your
webcam or any sort of camera and it lets
you read in frame by frame and you can
take apply whatever operations you need
to so in this case I had a Kara's model
which I was applying frame by frame and
then visualizing and that was quite easy
to do with OpenCV and so I took this
quick a quick and dirty model and and
tried it out and didn't work and the
reason why became obvious in hindsight
is the data is just not representative
of what a web camera what the real world
looks like there the lighting conditions
are quite complex compared to the green
the very clean image which I showed here
and you don't have clean you have to
identify the hand in the image and also
you might notice here there's the green
screen background also what's causing a
problem so to deal with that I decided
because I'm using deep learning let me
get some more data so that was the next
step was to go out and increase the
datasets through recording people and
also scraping forums engaging with the
sign community in the time frame so this
was quite a short project I did it as
part of a course and it's just a few
weeks time and I gathered several
gigabytes of video but I only manually
labelled around 300 images and I added
it to the dataset which wasn't a huge
amount but interesting interestingly was
was enough as you'll see to to actually
affect the output so I took these images
and now my dataset started to look
something like this so different skin
colors different shades more
representative of what you might see in
in the real world again so this
iteration 2 going through the
pre-processing pipeline this time I pad
it I also dropped the green Channel
because because of the the green screen
background which was just literally an
outline around the hand and I think was
causing some problems it was the network
can be learning just a
for a green outline which we don't have
and then again resizing it for the
neural network this time I have two
thousand images roughly 75 for class is
still not enough to train anything from
scratch so I went to use transfer link
and does everyone or does anyone ever
know transfer learning is okay cool so I
can use my pictures essentially transfer
learning is when we take large
pre-trained neural network architectures
often such as vgg 16 which i think is
from the University of Oxford and we can
use them as feature extractor so these
have been trained and the ones which are
open source have trained on the image
net challenge and then we can repurpose
it use them as feature extractors take
those features and repurpose it for
whatever use case so in in this for my
purpose it was a 26 class image
classification problem so I could drop
that last channel so there's an example
vgg 16 it uses a typical sort of image
recognition architecture so they're just
convolution blocks followed by max
pooling and at the end fully connected
layers in the softmax
output and a thousand classes which is
the image net competition for my
purposes I wanted to I dropped that
classification block and I just added
two fully connected layers with the
softmax activation so I get
probabilities per letter of the alphabet
and that lets me predict ya predict the
alphabet so all I actually need to do at
train time is train that last little
classification block after extracting
the features once through the through
the network and so I actually trained it
on my laptop in something like five
minutes on this MacBook Pro that's very
quickly transfer a link so in terms of
what's available for me to play with
this is all within chaos there's a few
architectures v g6
in nineteen which are older large ones
resident fifty an exception so I want to
talk about the technical details but
these are all within carats and they
just make it really easy for you to play
with and of particular interest for me
it was mobile net so this is a really
streamlined sort of compressed and
cut-down version of the exception
network which is useful for real-time
applications and especially on mobile
phones and things like that and again to
make you Sophie's you just go to care as
an import whichever architecture you
want to use and when you do that for
transfer learning you just you chop off
the classification block and you can
manually design your own sort of
features you can yeah have fun with that
so at this point I also realized that it
would be good to try and increase the
data set at some point and again K rise
you can do this using the image data
generator object these are just a few
parameters but there are more so you can
rescale here I've just applied random
rotations shifts shears just to make it
to deal with this really small dataset
and to try and make the most of what I
had so just using my get old code
snippet there and at each training he
put a random of a set of random
translations and rotations are applied
and yes so the results I did two tests I
wanted to train one with my
classification block and also the random
forests so where you can see with pretty
much all of them we reach a really high
accuracy and this is just is it the
right letter or not it's the top one
accuracy but the key metric for me here
given I wanted I wanted to be a
real-time system was the average frame
rate per second so your average YouTube
video could be anywhere from thirty to
sixty frames per second or or webcam but
with these with vgg sixteen and resident
if T which is
what I started out with you're getting
one to do friends per second it's very
laggy and just recently I think it was a
month ago
they included mobile net into chaos and
so I tried that out and immediately it
goes up to five frames per second just
out of the box putting it in and you
notice the accuracy as well as 99.7
using a classification block but with a
random forest it doesn't quite work as
well and these tests were all just on my
mic big Pro yeah might have damages CP a
bit but yeah so I went ahead and I took
the mobile architecture and I included
that into my my demo system again going
through the same loop so capturing video
doing the prediction and visualizing
it's all on its own github of you the
weights are up there if you want to try
it out I made a quick video just to give
you an example okay so this is V 216
it's extremely laggy but you can kind of
see that's a no it's a see yeah okay and
if you do with mobile net it just moves
much faster and much quicker and it's
yeah easier it works much better so as
you can probably tell there's a few
there's well quite a few this is a
project work in progress is a few things
I want to do a lot of ideas I have and
I'd welcome your ideas and criticisms
and if you're interested in
collaborating but I see a few ways ways
forward with it when I getting more data
as one actually moving on to translating
words and sentences so dynamic sort of
yeah so taking into the time series
aspect into account also thinking about
the real-time system in that video I
showed you I just had a Center crop
which I was taking and trans and doing
the prediction on that crop but really
it would be interesting to try and track
the hand and follow it and I tried that
with skin threshold and various things
but nothing is quite robust so it turns
out face detection is really well
implemented by hand to take
is a really open and active research
area because our hands can take so many
shapes so standard computer vision
features don't quite work and then again
I'm also working on porting some of this
to core ml and was a feedback from the
signing community was that a system like
this is very useful for us who can so we
can understand people but what there are
lovers is a well implemented
speech-to-text system which apparently
nobody nobody has done for them yet so
these are just ideas and I'd love if
anyone was interested in collaborating
to to get in touch thank you I'd like to
say thank you to the signing community
for helping me out and the data science
retreat and happy to take any questions
and talk about any of the type technical
aspects and some more detail
[Applause]